if I end up being an accountant I'm just
gonna throw this quiz in the trash
I studied acting and German and
entrepreneurship and did a bunch of
different stuff was an actor was a
writer worked for an ad agency for a
year I was a songwriter and a musician
and after that it led me into television
internet and film I essentially chose
whatever would pay the bills I really
want to see if my parents were right and
if I really should have been a lawyer
maybe show me something that I wouldn't
have considered as an option I don't
know I'm kind of nervous because I have
no idea what its gonna tell me Oh
which career would you rather have this
is hard cuz I think I feel like I want
to say celebrity stylist but my heart is
saying - math professor no bus driver no
youtuber yeah did I win yet nope there's
more questions despite what my apartment
looks like right now I'm organized I
feel like I'm pretty good at making
decisions however I'm here taking a quiz
to help me decide on my career which
best describes you I think it depends on
the situation probably but I'm actually
one of those people who like if
someone's upset on me and you confront
them like you're mad at me aren't you
can we talk about it you thrive in an
environment where you can immediately
see the results of your efforts I feel
the most confident and a low pressure
job that feels second nature to you in
the workplace you're not afraid to be
straightforward and direct the career
for you would include working in data
directing communications I've done that
who's okay or the fine arts Hey I think
I try to answer everything correctly but
I'm surprised by how accurate the seems
I tutor on the side and I love to teach
and it's something I considered for a
long time and I wonder if it's because
there's like this sort of personality
clash if you feel lost or confused about
what you should be doing with your life
it takes a lot of hard work to figure
that out I think it's a lot more
important for us to focus on the type of
person that we're actually becoming and
for us to do things that we enjoy life
is pretty long
you don't have to stick to one thing